nous sommes égaux 50 j'ai le seul groupe et
par conséquent nous avons tous une quantité égale
à dire et tout le monde a droit à cela
et finalement tout au long de ce
processus, nous passons par les cinq
personnes avant que la certaine direction
ne soit sur une chanson particulière ou  n'importe quelle
direction particulière de notre aura, j'ai
appris beaucoup de gars à Def Leppard
quelque part à Munich dans un
bar en croissance raisonnable et nous avons dit quelques mots
et je sais qu'ils étaient à Los Angeles je
suis allé m'asseoir et ils partent en une seule
étape  Je
vous,
notre carrière dure 20 années impaires, mais il
semble vraiment n'avoir été qu'une carrière
qui s'est allongée parce que nous
devons me trouver un écart entre les disques qui
sortent où nous avons façonné une nouvelle vie, vous
savez inévitablement qu'il le fera ce n'était
jamais  notre pensée si je dois toujours le
sortir de votre finition commune quand c'est
fini beaucoup de groupes aiment un élan
de leur succès et essaient juste de
sortir le produit vous savez d'accord nous avons
la contre-culture sur le disque
c'est un petit rendez-vous
répétons  pendant 24 heures
et nous faisons attention à Everett, je veux dire que
c'est vraiment énormément d'
énergie mentale est investie dans tous les aspects d'un
noyau, en particulier l'écriture dans les chansons
et finalement c'est de cela qu'il s'agit,
c'est une musique à petit budget qui était vraiment
encore  parce que nous avons un point à
prouver
chaque fois que nous sortons un album, c'est comme si
vous aviez deux domaines, nous sommes très fiers de ce que
nous avons fait et nous appelons toutes nos
expériences ensemble, nous avons une
union très étroite, vous savez que vous  jamais pensé que
ça vaut la peine de se rassembler pour conserver
la nuit avec spirituel ces choses
d'abord mieux pas de chevaux Ritz accident
que tous ces trucs puis vous prenez
ce bol et ensuite vous voulez l'utiliser
aussi et je suis un petit gang c'est
autorisé à faire  ce qu'il veut faire, ce sont les
ingrédients magiques des petits pains comme ceux qui sont sortis pour
la pierre à chignon et c'est ceci pour la
chimie aux cinq membres du chignon
vous ne pouvez pas l'acheter
Salomon vous ne vous divertissez même pas
je l'ai vous non plus  fais ou
tu ne fais pas
j'ai d'abord rencontré les gars et DEF LEPPARD
quelque part à Munich dans un très petit
bar à batterie et ils ont dit quelques
mots et c'était un peu tout et je
ne savais pas vraiment qui ils étaient à ce
moment-là  la prochaine chose qui m'est arrivée
était que je produisais ce jeune groupe de
garçons anglais en pensant qu'ils voulaient
sonner comme moi mais en fait tout ce qu'ils
voulaient faire avec un son comme leur limite
et j'en suis devenu assez content à
la fin et ils  dit bien vous devriez aller
le voir quand vous réalisez ce que nous voulons
dire
donc il se trouve que j'étais à Los Angeles
Lekhwiya maintenant et ils étaient sur le
forum de LA non je suis allé et je me suis assis et ils ont
fait n'importe quelle scène et j'avais été beaucoup
de  fois sur le forum, je n'avais jamais
rien vu de tel parce qu'à partir du
moment où ils sont montés sur scène jusqu'au moment où
ils sont partis jusqu'au dernier rappel,
personne ne s'est assis et moi y compris, j'étais
juste totalement dévasté, donc j'étais une
conversation à ce moment-là quoi  C'est arrivé,
ils savaient que j'étais là et ils m'ont demandé
de revenir et de jouer avec lui le
lendemain soir. J'étais sur scène avec lui
le lendemain soir au forum et je
n'oublierai jamais que c'était quelque chose
que
nous jouions.  Je pense et
j'ai failli me faire exploser par Ted partout où ma
chance de carburant que je suis ici maintenant ce que je
veux dire en substance à propos de ces vides,
c'est que ce genre de chose n'arrive pas
très souvent, vous avez un immense
talent que vous avez  une vision une sorte de
vision d'entreprise ou une vision partagée
entre certains jeunes gars, puis les
20 prochaines années de leur vie qu'ils
consacrent à la réalisation de cette vision et
beaucoup de choses difficiles leur sont arrivées
comme vous le savez tous et Joe
Elliott a sonné  moi la nuit où
Rick a eu son accident, son bras arraché
et il a dit eh bien vous n'allez pas
croire ce qui s'est passé et nous étions tous
comme stupéfaits jusqu'au cœur et Joe a dit que
peut-être qu'il ne tambourinerait plus jamais vous savez
peut-être qu'il ne le fait pas  Je ne revivrai plus à Rome
quelques mois plus tard, Joe m'a appelé et m'a dit que
riche en le faisant, il est de retour avec nous
et quoi qu'il en soit, vous savez tous maintenant qu'il s'est
rétabli, mais il n'est pas
seulement revenu à la batterie, mais il
a inventé un tout nouveau  style pour faire face au
fait de ce à quoi il avait affaire et
et Joe m'a dit autre chose il a
dit à cela quand tu as dit que ce n'est pas comme si nous
venions de revenir il a dit que nous avions
quelque chose d'autre en retour c'est comme si ça avait fait
quelque chose à  lire que ça a fait ressortir
quelque chose en lui il y a un esprit était une
force il y a une sorte de dignité et
de dévouement et voici une personne plus grande
à cause de cela et c'est vraiment ce que
je ressens pour tout le groupe car vous
savez qu'ils ont perdu le marché plus tard
et cherchent  Dieu pour l'amour de Dieu, il est à l'
origine des riffs, vous savez qu'il
est le pivot, vous savez qu'il est l'un
des grands écrivains et des riffs parce que de
notre génération, ils perdent ce gars et
encore une fois, vous savez qu'ils auraient pu
pleurer mais en fait ce qu'ils  ont
continué et ils ont continué avec
quelque chose de plus qu'ils ont grandi et ce qui est
défini mais qui est une sorte d'esprit
et ce n'est pas seulement une question de survie, je veux dire qu'ils
ont survécu et ont reçu une leçon qui est
merveilleuse mais ce qu'ils ont fait, c'est qu'ils
sont devenus  quelque chose de plus grand et de plus profond
et ce truc signifie quelque chose que vous savez que
ça vous fait pleurer ça vous fait rire ça
fait tout ce que vous savez ce n'est pas juste
produire une sorte de formule
définitivement régionale quelque chose comme ça c'est
vraiment ce n'est pas quelque chose que vous
recherchez ce n'est pas  quelque chose auquel vous
pensez même parce que je pense que si vous
commencez, vous savez et que vous commencez à imaginer
ce type d'occasion, alors vous avez gagné,
vous y êtes pour de mauvaises raisons jusqu'à ce que
vous n'arriviez jamais ici en premier lieu,
donc c'est c'est  bien quand ça arrive,
vous savez que nous avons toujours été fiers
de faire ce que nous faisons de notre mieux, nous pouvons,
espérons-le, vendre beaucoup de disques
parce que c'est le vrai
test le plus vrai et je suppose que les retombées
de la vente de beaucoup de disques c'est des choses
comme  ce que vous savez c'est je pense que
c'est plus un aliment d'honneur pour votre
famille et vos enfants dans les années à
venir peut-être regarder vous savez que c'est
bon c'est génial je veux dire c'est
complètement fou vraiment parce que c'est
tellement hors de la routine de quoi  nous
normalement, savez-vous que nous nous levons normalement
tard,
faites le concert, retournez à l'
hôtel ou montez dans un bus ou un avion ou
quoi que ce soit et vous savez si nous sommes dans un bus,
c'est parfois vous savez une nuit de 12 heures
à notre  la ville voisine et vous savez que
vous ne buvez que du café et plus de café
et de pain grillé et après votre entrée aujourd'hui
presque comme si nous nous sentions comme des rois, vous
savez que nous allions de la merde d'une
pièce à l'autre que de parler aux gens et
Brian a fait ces discours fantastiques dans Doc
pécheurs et vous savez qu'il y a toujours
des enfants qui applaudissent là-bas et nous devons
nous salir les mains et certains des
autres artistes qui sont là-bas que
vous savez que vous allez être à
côté de vous Jimmy Page et des gens comme
ça vous  sais c'est c'est c'est très
flatteur c'est c'est
un bon moment c'est vraiment bien
que nous avons évidemment dit vous
savez que ce n'est pas du
tout une
corvée
vraiment vraiment cool en fait j'aime juste
l'idée d'être inclus
vous savez une fois pour toutes vous savez que nous le
faisons depuis longtemps vous savez c'est pour
avoir de l'air et des accessoires vous savez et
le fait que c'est un mensonge vous savez nous
vivent en quelque sorte dans la région, donc c'est un peu
ces chiffres locaux qui allaient
bien manger, c'était encore une fois un autre
jour étrange parce que vous savez que nous venons de
terminer l'album et j'ai toujours été
certifié dix millions ou quelque chose que vous
savez a sorti son diamant  Le prix était
normalement quand vous devenez or ou platine,
ce qu'il fait, c'est en quelque sorte simplement dire hé votre
disque est devenu platine et six mois
plus tard, vous faites une séance photo avec ce
disque et votre MD que vous connaissez bien et votre
manager parce qu'ils n'ont jamais eu
eux avant qu'ils ne décident de faire tout le monde
le même jour, alors ils en ont fait un grand grand
événement, donc nous étions encore la même chose,
vous savez, il y a Jimmy Page Elton John
et il y a tous ces
artistes vraiment célèbres et il y a le bon vieux
Def Leppard dans  il y a parmi tout ça
comme ça c'est génial tu sais il
n'y a pas beaucoup de groupes qui l'ont fait
pour penser que nous y étions réellement accomplis
cela ne veut pas dire que tu sais que nous
regardons très rarement en arrière ils passent très rarement
regarde en arrière nous regardons en arrière quand  nous avons en quelque sorte
demandé ou dit à presque vous savez que nous
recherchons toujours la prochaine chose, mais
de temps en temps, c'est agréable de s'arrêter et de sentir
les roses ou de supposer et vous savez que vous vous
tenez là et que vous regardez autour de vous
et que vous pensez bon Dieu
tu sais qu'il n'y a personne des
Rolling Stones ici parce qu'ils
n'ont pas fait un disque de 10 millions de ventes
et il pense wow tu me connais en fait
pense que c'est ce qui m'a attiré, ce sont
les artistes qui n'étaient pas là c'est
quoi  vraiment parce que vous savez que j'ai grandi en
écoutant tout le monde et la moitié de ceux que
tout le monde n'était pas proches, vous
savez et cela vous donne l'impression qu'il a
probablement
encore réalisé quelque chose, je veux dire que nous
parlions juste de Brian May,
je veux dire il il est  le gars qui nous a présenté
ce déshonneur et je dois vraiment
dire que c'est quand j'ai entendu
Queen pour la première fois que ça a changé ma vie ça
m'a donné envie de vouloir être dans un
groupe de rock et un groupe de rock ça j'ai toujours en
quelque sorte  écouté les groupes les plus lourds
comme j'ai exactement nob comme Sabbath
et puis cette fois-là ça faisait aussi partie de
Zeppelin au moins mais quand j'ai entendu Queen
c'était c'était le Libyen a dit le
truc pop il avait assez de guitares rock élément rock
et ce mélodique  contenu qui s'est
réuni et je n'ai jamais entendu quelque chose
comme ça auparavant et littéralement à partir de
leur troisième album, l'
album de crise cardiaque pure que quand j'avais environ 13 ans,
tout à coup, j'ai entendu et s'est bien passé, je n'ai
jamais rien entendu de tel et de
alors c'est ouais tu commentes tu as
différentes influences en cours de route mais
c'était le point de départ définitif
tu ne perds jamais vraiment que c'est tout un
plan que tu commences il n'y en a pas
vraiment un je suis un je suis un hybride de
mille  artistes qui est la meilleure façon
d'être, vous savez si vous avez remarqué quand
quatre-vingt-dix van Halen sont sortis de nulle part
et c'était époustouflant et des gens comme
Frank Zappa disaient merci d'avoir
réinventé la guitare électrique a B mais
quatre ans plus tard nous avions un  millions de
clones d'Eddie Van Halen et les gens disent à Phil que
tu sais d'où vient ton style
pour jouer de la guitare et il dit bien il
dit que je n'écoute pas seulement Eddie Van
Halen et essaie de copier les miss j'aime
Eddie Van Halen mais j'ai aussi  j'adore Ritchie
Blackmore et Jimi Hendrix et je suis un
peu de tout ça et c'est pareil pour
moi tu sais c'est le gars qui en fait je
pense qu'une petite étincelle se déclenche dans ton
cerveau quand tu me connais à environ 10 11 12
ans et il est comme  ouais soit ça
va être un braqueur de banque d'un footballeur
ou une pop star vous savez et c'était voir
Marc Bolan sur Top of the Pops faire ouais eh
bien il s'appelait get it on en Angleterre
il s'appelait bang a gong en Amérique
ouais ouais et ça  c'était juste le voir c'était
c'était je ne sais pas ce que c'est
parce que nous savons que marc bolan était très
efféminé à une seconde vous savez si
boas de plumes femmes chaussures brillent
sur son visage et à 12 ans
j'étais  extrêmement hétérosexuel donc je ne
sais pas quelle était l'attirance je n'ai jamais
compris ça je pense que c'est le
côté artistique de moi est un peu si
tout ce qui va bien je n'ai pas de
problème avec ça
et puis garçon même le  même chose, il y a
Bowie qui agite comme des justaucorps et Rouge
et qui ressemble à une sorte de
poupée kimono ou ces poupées japonaises et
quoi que ce soit, mais il faisait la star
Manon et John Je ne fais que danser et et
et c'était juste époustouflant mais vraiment
c'était c'était ballin et Bowie étaient les
deux principales choses qui m'ont donné envie
d'être dans la musique mais la Karen a dit que je me
suis avéré être un copiste de l'un d'
eux parce que je ne m'intègre pas à distance et
tout ce qu'ils ont jamais  c'est fait je veux dire
nous vous savez que nous n'avons parfois pas vu
écrire des chansons comme nous l'avons fait nous avons enregistré
beaucoup de toujours des trucs avant mais je ne
sonne pas comme Bowie sinon je suis comme balle et
je n'agis pas  comme l'un ou l'autre, mais il y a
de si grandes influences sur moi juste pour me mettre en fait
dans l'entreprise en
premier lieu, vraiment tout
l'anglais est très différent là-bas, vous
savez, nous beaucoup de gens pensent toujours que nous
vivons en Angleterre, nous avons en quelque sorte déménagé  il a
toujours aimé la musique américaine, vous savez
si c'était Motown Beach Boys
quoi que vous sachiez et c'est de là que
vient la musique rock, cela fait juste partie d'une
culture américaine, c'est ainsi que nous
en devenons fans et c'est aussi l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles les gens y vont  L'
Amérique est votre accent américain unique
et c'est parce que nous apprenons des
groupes américains, donc je suis juste tout ce qu'une
radio anglaise anglaise est très limitée,
vous avez comme une ou deux stations et des
stations pirates qui dirigent les enfants, c'est
comme s'ils venaient de maintenant mais c'est  beaucoup de
Riley, même des types de
musique différents, mais en
grandissant, vous savez que vous avez entendu certains des meilleurs
trucs marocains et c'est ce qui
nous a vraiment rendu accro, puis plus tard, ce sont
des groupes qui vous ont également fait
savoir que c'est exactement  et les pierres
et les bagels et tout
ça et ça et nous avons été emportés par ça
aussi euh assez drôle quand j'ai rejoint ce
groupe Joe et j'ai réalisé que nous avions tous les deux
été motivés pour entrer dans la musique par
exactement la même personne sur  exactement ce qu'il y a
dans l'émission télévisée et c'était marc
bolan l'émission t-rex intitulée Top of the
Pops, donc à partir de ce moment-là, j'ai porté
les vêtements de ma sœur bien avant
son maquillage pour aider jusqu'à ce point, vous
savez, comme tout le monde qui grandit
aux Britanniques  Dans les îles ou en Europe, vous
vouliez être un joueur de football, en
général, tout le clan, il y a beaucoup
de bonne musique qui est sortie au début des
années 70, vous savez ce qu'Elton John
allait dire en écrivant le Suédois et oserais-je
dire Carrie Clara tous ces groupes glamour
mais c'était une très bonne époque pour la
musique pop et vous savez que c'est quelque chose que
je pense qu'il s'agissait d'une grande
sensibilité pop Def Leppard c'est souvent
appelé à tort un groupe de rock Je
ne pense pas que ce soit nécessairement ça a été
une chanson  puis j'ai balancé le chapeau vers la mélodie il
y avait il y avait un certain nombre de
groupes américains que j'aimais vraiment comme
je me souviens avoir écouté Barnstorm pour
la première fois Joe Walsh lui tout ce que
vous savez ce que je trouvais incroyable
mais nous nous avons aussi grandi avec l'ensemble
une sorte de truc glam en Angleterre qui était
vous savez comme doux et léger et vous
connaissez Blackburn Queen donc ce serait que c'était
vieux qui avait aussi une sorte de grande
influence sur
parfois vous n'obtenez pas votre chemin
c'est comme de toute façon je vais  grimpe avec
mes pieds maintenant je suis inspiré par le nom eh bien
tu n'abandonnes pas si tu ne le fais pas si tu si tu
ne restes pas appelle ça au moins
ce n'est pas un mauvais savoir signifie aussi simple que ça
tu sais si si tu ne le fais pas  ne prenez pas les
sentiments de l'autre en considération si
vous ne parcourez pas une route ensemble à la
même vitesse et au même rythme, alors vous savez
abandonner soit vous savez qu'il n'y a personne qui
prend la balle et court avec elle dans
ce groupe c'est comme si c'était un collectif
c'est un  c'est une démocratie c'est une
coopérative
nous sommes tous monsieur 20% ce qui veut dire que
parfois tu n'y arrives pas
ça veut dire aussi parfois quand il y a
un problème c'est pour les gens qui
le partagent quand elle est bonne alors tu sais que
c'est la quintessence absolue  d'un homme,
cette chose lipidique maintenant, je veux dire, vous savez, mais
j'ai le respect ultime pour tous
ces gars et la grande chose à ce sujet
est que je sais que même Vivian a été
dans le groupe seulement huit ans, nous nous connaissons à
fond nous  savoir quand
laisser quelqu'un avec vous, vous pouvez dire par le
simple regard que quelqu'un a des problèmes,
vous savez qu'ils ont leurs propres problèmes
aujourd'hui ou à cette minute particulière, alors hé,
je ne vais pas le déranger avec comme
lequel de vous idiots a chanté le  mauvaise note
hier soir dans bla bla bla ou ils
ne vont pas me dire tu sais que tu
apprends juste à t'éloigner quand tu dois te
détacher quand tu as besoin à peu près de nos
vies d'adulte
je veux dire j'ai 41 ans j'ai été  son fan depuis que je
n'avais que 18 ans,
eh bien, quelqu'un m'a déjà posé une
question similaire et cela transcende
tout ce qui a à voir avec la musique,
cela revient simplement à l'
amitié, l'une des raisons pour lesquelles nous sommes
ensemble en tant qu'équipe et l'ensemble  une sorte d'
alchimie derrière ça tu sais que tu es une
véritable inspiration pour beaucoup qui doit être
réelle tu sais que c'est cette énorme rue à double sens
parce que je rencontre des gens qui sont
dans des situations bien pires que moi et
je m'en inspire tellement  du
temps que ça marche ça marche à l'opposé des
menthes ils plantent la graine que nous pouvons
Ospital je me
souviens d'y être allé oh nous
n'avions vraiment pas hâte d'y être nous
ne savions pas nous ne savions pas à quoi nous
attendre nous pensions  ça va être
juste un horrible genre de larmes l'
un dans l'autre et tout ça et ça déchire
comme de toute façon je vais jouer
avec mes pieds et j'étais comme juste
positif dès le départ et il n'y avait
aucune sorte de non  l'apitoiement sur soi ne pas s'attarder sur
le négatif c'était juste comme positif
nous avons été choqués nous avons juste été époustouflés
et puis il s'est séparé le suivant je ne
sais pas ouais nous réveillant tous les matins
vivait dans le même appartement à
Dublin dans le  nouvelle technique que nous
ne jouerons pas de la batterie directement dans l'eau c'était
génial et c'était juste très encourageant
nous avons toujours été notoirement lents notre
carrière a duré 20 années impaires mais il
semble vraiment n'avoir été qu'une carrière
qui s'est étirée maintenant parce que  il y a eu
ces plafonds de cinq ans
entre les disques qui sortent où nous avons
juste traversé la vie, vous savez, jamais
très pressés de le faire, cela n'a jamais été notre
truc puisque je dois toujours le sortir
ce bruit c'est fini quand c'est
fini c'est fini  quand c'est la
qualité et non la quantité qui a toujours été
notre règle, donc depuis que nous avons commencé à
travailler avec plus, cela a toujours été vous
savez peu importe comment vous y arrivez
tant que vous y arrivez et la qualité au
coin
et ce ne sont que deux bases que Matos
mais vous savez, nous nous sommes améliorés dans ce que
nous faisons,
la seule chose que nous avons toujours voulu
faire était de nous améliorer.
le troisième ou leur quatrième album et ce que
vous avez, c'est que vous avez ceci en constante
amélioration du premier disque au
deuxième tiers au quatrième et le
quatrième euh était comme ce disque classique un
gros violet profond dans le rock ou quoi que vous
savoir quel est le chignon et puis ils
semblent juste aller comme ça
et nous ne voulons jamais que ce soit ce genre de
groupe ce que c'est qu'ils sont encore environ
20 ans après leur meilleur disque nous avons
toujours vous savez si vous y parvenez
ou  pas encore une fois subjectif mais nous
voulions juste continuer à aller de mieux en mieux
je suis un meilleur chanteur maintenant que je ne l'étais l'
année dernière j'étais un meilleur chanteur l'année dernière
il y avait un an avant et ainsi de suite et ainsi de
suite vous connaissez beaucoup de gens  Je trouve
qu'ils ont mon âge et
qu'ils ne peuvent plus vraiment jouer les notes
parce que vous savez qu'ils seraient trop occupés à
se saouler et c'est comme si j'avais
toujours mis l'accent sur si je devais jouer à
ce jeu rock stardom ou  peu importe et je ne
suis jamais né avec la meilleure voix du
monde, je dois travailler beaucoup plus dur
que ces autres personnes que je pensais un peu comme
un gâchis, donc ça a toujours
été mon truc facile de monter sur scène
laisser l'aigle sur scène  Je le prends c'est
comme si c'était comme un culte Je mets ma
peau de léopard Colton c'est mon ego Je
ne l'ai pas dans la loge et je
l'ai sur scène Je vais intimider je vais taquiner je
vais battre je vais embrasser et caresser  un
public mais dès que nous terminons le
concert, je coche le culte et puis juste
moi quelque chose sur ce niveau II est bien
plus à un niveau subconscient c'est AIT c'est
un lien qui se produit et une
compréhension qui défie presque la
conversation parfois avec ça
j'ai  remarqué personnellement même sur scène
il y a sans avoir l'air trop mystique et
un arty il y a un lien télépathique certain
entre moi et Rick et je sais que
je peux sentir quand il va faire une
erreur ou pas nécessairement une erreur
jouerait quelque chose de différent
ou vice versa avec moi  généralement une
erreur, mais c'est mais vous avez une sensation
et pendant les 10 secondes suivantes, vous
traversez quelque chose qui n'est pas tout à fait ce qu'il
n'était pas la nuit précédente, puis vous
y revenez
afin que vous n'ayez pas développé des choses comme ça
si vous '  en être conscient tout le temps
ou pas c'est une autre question l'une des
choses l'une des raisons étaient encore là
ce que nous
faisons et nous rassemblons toutes nos expériences,
nous avons une union très étroite, vous
savez que les femmes pensent que les jumeaux
grandiraient ensemble, vous
savez que nous avons vécu toutes ces choses,
les naissances, les décès, les mariages, les divorces, les
accidents que tout cela et vous
prenez tout  à bord et vous écrivez de la
musique aussi et c'est un petit jeu
qui est autorisé à faire ce qu'il veut faire
Je ne suis pas plus fatigué que n'importe qui d'autre pour
faire un travail vous savez je veux dire je suis
fatigué de parler le matin si je '  Je
suis debout depuis 20 heures, vous savez que je suis fatigué
de le faire et vous savez qu'un cas sur ma
voix devient un peu corde parce que les
horaires sont ce qui perd votre voix pas
encore ce n'est pas ce n'est pas un problème de capacité,
c'est littéralement faire tellement de spectacles  en
si peu de temps ou sur
une si longue période de temps sans
pauses décentes et si vous attrapez un rhume,
il ne peut jamais se réparer correctement parce que vous
renoncez à planer et pendant qu'il est encore en train de
guérir et parce qu'il y a un horaire
à respecter -  mais je ne suis pas du tout fatigué de ça
comme je l'ai dit j'ai 41 ans je suis
en fait plus enthousiaste à ce sujet maintenant
que je ne l'étais alors
quand tu as 20 21 tu ne penses jamais que ça
va se terminer je suis assez réaliste  de se
rendre compte que tôt ou tard c'est donc j'en
profite à chaque seconde en ce
moment je veux dire bien les cinq autres 10 ou
les 15 ans qui sait mais tu sais que je suis
conscient de notre mortalité maintenant ils savent que je
n'avais pas 20 ans  il y a des années, eh
bien, je ne vois pas pourquoi
Jagr n'a pas cinq ans de plus que ça et
il y va toujours, je veux dire si vous regardez
Steven Tyler oh et David Bowie, je veux dire que
ces gars n'ont l'air que d'environ 25 ou 30
ans d'un  distance au moins
ces gars ont l'air super et ils ont de l'
enthousiasme pour ça
et je pense que tant que vous avez de l'
enthousiasme pour ça et que vous ne
vous laissez pas en quelque sorte vous effondrer
physiquement et mentalement et vous pouvez
toujours écrire et  effectuer je ne vois pas pourquoi
pas parce que le rock and roll maintenant il a 50
ans ou peut-être même plus tu sais
ou il a 45 ans je te demande pardon
quoi qu'il en soit et dans le sept c'est que tu es vieux
à 32 parce que c'était encore jeune il y
avait  une jeune industrie maintenant ça fait partie de
la culture américaine et je ne crois pas vraiment
qu'il y ait un problème avec
les gens qui voient un Peter Frampton ou un
Lynyrd Skynyrd ou un Rolling Stones ou un
paul mccartney tu es une mauvaise compagnie ou un
plan de téléavertisseur ou  Des musiciens des années 50 ou David Bowie 50
quelque chose que vous allez
connaître sur scène et ils font un
excellent travail et beaucoup de gens sont toujours
heureux de payer de l'argent pour aller le voir
jouer, il ne semble pas y avoir de
stigmatisation sur l'âge  comme ils l'étaient, je veux
dire que vous pourriez toujours avoir une carrière d'
une manière ou d'une autre ou faire glisser le nom du groupe
dans le sang, mais je ne pense pas que cela
dise honnêtement quand j'avais 20 ans, je pensais que 30
tu dois plaisanter  je
plaisante
ouais j'ai 42 ans maintenant et c'est comme si c'était facile c'est
amusant nous faisons ce que nous voulons faire
et nous le faisons avec des gens
comme nous l'avons dit si nous sentons toujours que c'était
vital et important les uns pour les autres
dans  dans dix ans, nous serons toujours là
et pour être assez bien, nous savons qu'un bon pourrait
oh, nous pourrions tous malheureusement ne pas être à l'
antenne la semaine prochaine, j'en doute beaucoup, mais
quand vous arrivez quand vous êtes là
depuis aussi longtemps  comme nous le savons, vous unissez
juste vous le prenez au jour le jour, profitez-en,
cela ne signifie pas que le contenu est
en fait un peu difficile, mais c'est
amusant, je veux dire, évidemment, nous avons trois
gars qui vivent en Californie, deux gars vivent
en Irlande, donc quand nous commençons initialement
l'écriture, nous écrivons en tant qu'individus, nous apportons
le travail individuel à la
table collective et nous éliminons, vous savez, je veux dire évidemment
toutes les Alpes, une pièce pourrait prendre en
premier et si la chanson passe, personne ne
dit rien, ils n'aiment pas ça mais si
c'est comme  wow c'est génial c'est vraiment
bien tu sais qu'ils veulent faire une
chanson mais ensuite nous aurons des yeux de léopard il
faut que ce soit un peu plus de cette Isabella
quand Vivian a apporté la chanson pour être vivante
à la table ça ne ressemblait pas du tout
à la façon dont  ça s'est terminé sur l'euphorie c'est
exactement la même mélodie même paroles même
clé tout mais nous l'avons juste fait comme si
c'était la différence entre Frank
Sinatra et Sid Vicious sa version de
ma façon
même chanson juste une approche différente vous
savez ce que vous faites est si vous croyez en
la chanson que vous venez d'arranger pour convenir au
groupe alors que Vivian ferait une démo
pour convenir à Vivian et je ferai ma
démo m'a trempé alors vous devez permettre à
tout le monde d'être là important en tant
qu'interprète ce n'est pas trop difficile si
les chansons  c'est génial tu es loin et
ce ne sont que des chansons individuelles alors nous allons
le regarder ensemble quelqu'un peut trouver
juste un riff et ensuite nous le travaillons
avec Jamie et ensuite vous vous retrouvez avec une
chanson écrite par deux ou trois quatre ou
cinq personnes  comme la chanson papier est écrite
par six personnes que vous connaissez et puis il y a d'
autres chansons qui sont écrites par une
personne c'est des chevaux pour les cours
pour moi les grandes différences dans l'éthique de travail
- quand nous afficherons sera la fin du
monde
je ne pourrais pas nécessairement  faire beaucoup d'autre
nous sommes collectivement partout où l'Italie
nous ne savons pas vraiment je veux dire que vous avez
beaucoup de théories nous Vivian a probablement une
meilleure perspective à ce sujet mais le reste d'entre
nous n'a jamais rien connu d'autre vraiment
comme vous connaissez une vision vous  sais qu'il est le
nouveau garçon que tu ne connais même pas avec ses 8 ans
il tu sais qu'il a probablement vu quelques
groupes différents et nous sommes vous savez pour
moi la grande différence est l'éthique de travail
vous connaissez beaucoup de groupes juste l'
élan de leur  succès et essayez de
sortir le produit et vous savez,
d'accord, nous avons 10 ou 12 chansons pour un disque, c'est
ça qui fera l'affaire,
répétons pendant 24 heures et allons vers
elle et avec Def Leppard, je veux dire il y en a
vraiment beaucoup  d'
énergie mentale est mise dans tous les aspects qu'il y
avait mais surtout l'écriture des
chansons et finalement c'est de cela qu'il s'agit, c'est à
propos de la musique, ce n'est pas
à propos de la coiffure ou des beaux prix
ou quoi que ce soit que vous sachiez donc c'est
pourquoi le Bannock je suppose  il a fallu tellement
de temps pour faire des disques et comme Rick l'a dit,
vous savez parce que j'ai joué dans d'autres
groupes, j'ai cela par contraste et
quand j'ai rejoint cet homme, je
ne pouvais tout simplement pas croire le dévouement qu'il
y a envers le travail comparé  avec
des gens avec qui j'ai travaillé dans le passé, je
veux dire qu'il y a beaucoup de gens très talentueux
dans l'industrie, mais il
faut aussi une certaine bravoure
de la part des membres du groupe
pour critiquer leur propre travail pour
le regarder  et puis dire bon d'accord que c'est ça
pourrait être mieux parce que tu t'attaches beaucoup
quand tu m'écris des chansons en tant
qu'individu et nous travaillons tous sur des chansons à
la maison par nous-mêmes et nous les apportons à la
table et il faut être capable d'avaler
ta fierté et ton ego pour l'
amélioration du groupe qui
finira par être pour l'amélioration
de cette chanson particulière mais beaucoup de
gens deviennent très précieux à propos de leur
chanson je sais que c'est mon art bien je suis avec
lui tout le temps  Je n'ai jamais été loin
de lui si longtemps que j'avais envie de nous remettre
ensemble parce que nous venons d'avoir cette
pause de quatre mois et je téléphonais à
tout le monde après quatre ou cinq semaines
peut-être ouais je n'étais pas tellement désespéré de
sauter dessus  un avion et aller et comme un lien un
lien féminin roulant dans les bois nom
moi-même dans l'huile d'arbre et tout ça mais nous sommes
toujours ensemble et nous l'avons toujours été
et je pense qu'il est juste devenu ce que c'est
sans même y penser juste
la routine c'est comme  mémoire musculaire, nous sommes
ensemble et vous savez, quand nous ne sommes pas
ensemble, peut-être pour certains d'entre nous pour une
raison quelconque si nous en
montrons une partie, ce sera un soulagement
pour les autres, ce sera la fin du
monde et  il faudra beaucoup d'ajustements
pour s'habituer à ne pas avoir le vrai sur lequel vous
savez que les autres gars peuvent compter et vous
savez tout d'un coup que vous devez faire un
album solo ou faire une tournée solo ou nous prenons tous
juste notre retraite ou  peu importe, mais nous sommes juste
ce que nous sommes en ce moment et c'est une
question très différente à laquelle vous
savez être tout à fait honnête, car à
part juste prendre un peu de temps
entre les tournées, nous devons toujours
y arriver de toute façon, sachez qu'il y a  un besoin parce que
vous savez que nous avons un contrat
avec une maison de disques et que nous avons
artistiquement et que nous devons être les uns avec les
autres parce que ce que nous ne sommes pas, vous savez que
nous ne sommes pas des idiots, nous voyons à quel point la
tournée des Rolling Stones et les chiens d'album
par rapport à un disque solo de Mick Jagger,
il est la plus grande rock star de la planète,
personne n'achète ses disques solo et à quoi ça
sert qu'ils en fassent un, nous sommes
collectivement tout ce que nous allons
vraiment faire et nous apprécions ça et c'est comme
si vous pouviez  acceptez qu'il ne s'agit pas
de se cacher derrière quoi que ce soit, c'est comme si
être réaliste était définitivement le meilleur
coup que nous ayons tous eu en tête-à
-tête avec Madonna Michael Jackson Elton
John Backstreet Boys Britney Spears vous
savez et vous savez que c'est le défi de
faire  que vous savez que c'est le défi
de faire ça plutôt que d'être simplement
un autre groupe de rock, c'est juste sur l'une de
ces tournées à forfait des années 80 avec de grands
groupes de laque pour cheveux ou nous savons pour nous que
ce n'est pas ce que nous sommes vraiment dans
les deux choses ensemble sont imparables
vous savez que vous obtenez un renforcement positif
de la part des gens autour de vous, que ce soit
les gars du groupe ou
et puis cela m'a permis de puiser dans
une force que je n'avais jamais ressentie
en moi-même, donc c'est juste une
combinaison de choses mais ensuite je remercie
toi, mais j'ai réalisé que je ne pouvais pas, je ne pouvais pas
nécessairement faire grand-chose d'autre,
alors je voulais que ça marche.  qui était
brûlée,
elle a dit qu'elle ne serait pas sortie
normalement mais elle est sortie parce qu'elle
voulait rencontrer Rick et que ce n'était qu'un
voyage en soi, vous savez que le fait qu'elle soit
entrée, elle s'est tellement brûlée qu'elle les
membres vont oh  bien bien celui-ci a
baisé celui-ci est mort et et ils ont
pris et elle était comme une brûlure et
elle doit porter un bas de corps elle
n'a pas de lèvres et elle est venue et elle
avait fait le tour c'était
Rick surtout tu sais  fait l'œuf que
nous continuerons et c'est ce qui est
fantastique parce que je fais partie de
ce club et je peux dire des choses pour les
gens et ils peuvent me dire des choses
que je n'aurais pas nécessairement été un
je serais  Je n'ai pas pu m'en tirer
ou je ne serais pas dans ce club
si j'avais deux bras, nous sommes égaux, la cinquième partie
fait partie d'un groupe et par conséquent, nous
avons tous notre mot à dire et
tout le monde a droit  cela et
finalement tout au long du processus
que nous traversons, les cinq personnes
ont évolué dans une certaine direction sur une
chanson particulière ou une
direction particulière d'un album ou quoi que ce soit
que c'est probablement ce qui
prend beaucoup de temps, c'est que nous donnons à
chacun  autre le respect de mettre leur
point de vue en avant et parfois je peux
prendre beaucoup de temps eh
bien nous sommes sortis depuis 15 mois ces orteils ont
été une tournée de 15 mois qui est la
plus longue à avoir jamais fait nous avons nous
avons deux modes de  transport nous avons le
bus d'attaque et nous avons le bus végétarien
et c'est aussi le genre de non-
bébés et le bus pour bébés donc tout
fonctionne
vous savez que nous avons la plupart du temps que vous
savez que les enfants ne sont pas sur la route  Rory a
été rempli de dix personnes maintenant, donc
il est presque l'assistant d'un manager, le
processus général, je veux dire, l'
aspect tournée des choses est généralement facile une fois que
nous avons répété les tournées que nous sortons sur
scène, nous sommes relativement confiants
dans ce que nous faisons  sur scène, c'est un peu
un jeu d'enfant pour être juste, l'
écriture et l'aspect enregistrement, c'est
un certain style que nous avons en
quelque sorte développé nous-mêmes, mais depuis
le milieu des années 80 et c'est un
chose difficile à garder - parce que vous faites
les choses d'une certaine manière pour obtenir un
certain son dans un certain style et
à travers toute la technologie, ce n'est
peut-être pas si facile parce que si ce
n'était pas le cas et je suis sûr qu'il y en aurait quelques
autres  les gens ou quelques autres groupes de notre
acabit en Chine sonnent comme ceux-là et ce
n'est pas une chose facile à faire et c'est
quelque chose auquel vous devez être très
dévoué bien si j'agenouille la réponse
à cela, je le mettrais en bouteille et le vendrais  c'est un
magasin d'ouverture qui rapporte des millions mais ma
théorie est que c'est une combinaison de beaucoup d'
ingrédients différents vraiment je pense que
nous avons la même direction depuis 79
donc il y a une relation là-bas qui est
assez solide nous avons eu le même
commerce de disques en 79 même  chose et nous
avons à peu près la même programmation depuis
79, c'est évidemment quand Steve est
mort, nous avons Vivienne et Phil
remplaçant Pete Willis mais je veux dire que
les films sont dans environ 18 ans et nous
connaissons le film depuis 79 donc il  était-ce un
réseau, vous savez que nous nous aimons,
les musiques ont toujours été l'objectif commun et
il y a l'ingrédient magique que les
groupes aiment n'a pas que les autres groupes
n'ont pas et c'est juste que c'est la chimie
entre les cinq membres du groupe vous  vous
ne pouvez pas l'acheter
vous ne pouvez pas le planifier vous ne pouvez même pas
vous éduquer pour l'avoir
soit vous le faites soit vous ne le faites pas
certaines personnes sont nées avec la capacité de
prendre un crayon et de dessiner parfaitement et
certaines personnes  pense quand ils ne peuvent pas, tu
sais sans avoir de cours ou
quoi que ce soit et d'autres personnes peuvent avoir toutes
les leçons qu'ils veulent et c'est de la
foutaise
tu sais c'est juste que tu as de la chance et
c'est ce que c'est bien j'aime beaucoup
le destin impliqué et  beaucoup de chance,
mais c'est la chimie est l'
ingrédient important et c'est le seul
élément voyou si vous aimez parce que vous ne pouvez pas le
planifier, c'est juste que c'est juste là et
vous découvrez au fur et à mesure que c'est
là et ça a été  là et
j'espère qu'il sera toujours là à l'
avenir